okay guys to put it simply I had to do
this video I've gotten so many requests
you see them by the title it's a
requested video but I can't put everyone
who's requested its name in the in the
description box because there's just too
many have too many people and too many
channels I've recorded who have
requested this video I can't even talk
so if you have requested this video this
is for you and hopefully you will be
able to get the best recording quality
out of Camtasia Studio 6 if you don't
have it already I highly suggest you get
it is one of the best screen recorders
you can get so I'm basically thanks for
watching and I hope you enjoy and I hope
you learn a lot so enjoy this tutorial
hello everybody and welcome to another
HD tutorial and this one I'll be showing
you exactly how I get the highest
quality out of the recordings that I do
with Camtasia Studio 6 you may have
noticed my past couple of videos about
my past dozen videos have actually been
recorded using Camtasia Studio 6 and
I've gotten a lot of requests lately
about how I get such high quality in
such good resolution when actually
recording my videos so when we're going
to produce a video in Camtasia Studio 6
first of all we have to make our video
so I'm not even going to do any editing
I'm just going to drag in my intro ok
and my outro now this first initial step
that I'm doing right now won't actually
happen with you where you search and you
choose YouTube 720p so we're going to
create this so we're going under the
produce tab and go to batch production
and we're going to go to actually we're
going to go to add files and projects
and just choose any video that you
actually want to produce an HD I'll just
choose the lake video right here enter
and go to next now we go to preset
manager this is where we are going to
create a new preset and this is going to
be the crease that we use for every
single video that we produce in 720p so
I've actually dyed it already I named it
720p so I'm just going to go going to
edit for you so I can show you all the
settings that I use and that you can
copy them down and hopefully they'll
work best for you so first of all the
fire file format that we want to save it
in is MOV and if I haven't told you
already you're going to need QuickTime
and I'll put the QuickTime link in the
description but basically you're gonna
go to Apple comm and make sure you have
QuickTime so you can play these movies
and use them so next we're going to it
just hit next and it will bring us to
the next step of publishing a video now
this step here QuickTime options is the
most important part there's video
settings and sound settings first go to
settings for video and you'll see my
compression type is h.264 if it isn't
all automatically just go from a
drop-down menu and take tich h.264 also
this should be current absolutely no
this should be automatic so I'm just
going to click automatic and this should
be 30
frames-per-second okay if it isn't
already go ahead and take it out 30
frames per second and that is basically
it also you're going to want to make
this 30 frames per second just to make
sure the keyframes match up here and
tick frame recording down here for the
compressor go to best quality okay and I
go for best quality multipass encoding
so that's who that's basically what
we're going to do for that so we hit
okay then we're going to go into sound
settings and we hit settings again and
just make sure it is 4800 kilohertz if
it isn't already make it mpeg-4 audio
and 4800 kilohertz as well as 16-bit and
stereo stereo works very well especially
if you have two mics like I do then
you'll get the best quality sound out of
your recording so hit OK for that and
then we're going to hit OK and our
settings are safe to go to next and this
is where we basically we need to make
sure this is 1280 by 720 for the highest
quality uploading to youtube now if you
are recording a say a 1900 by 1200
screen like I am you can save to that
but it will not translate completely to
YouTube the highest that you can
actually watch on YouTube is 1280 by 720
if your screen is larger or smaller then
the background color will be this so if
you zoom out on your video like so then
you'll have this particular background
color in the background of your video
first modern 16 by 9 so I'm going to I'm
not going to disable call-out effects or
zooming pan speed reduce because I'm I
don't really mind the size of the video
it never gets too big for me to upload
then I hit next and that is basically
all you have to do for the HD quality
now if you do want to include a
watermark like you may see at the top
right hand corner of this page just in
options and I already showed you guys
how to make a watermark now you can just
choose how big or small horizontal
anything you want about your watermark
and just get your watermark from
clicking this little open icon here so
that's where you get it and then you
just hit finish when you're done I'm
going to hit cancel because I don't want
to destroy anything and now whenever you
want to include a video in HD you go to
produce produce video as and you select
this 720p the YouTube HD format that
you've just created just click on it hit
next name it and I always like to
uncheck the subfolders one so it just
gives me the one MOV file hit next and
it begins to produce so I'm gonna hit
cancel because I don't want to just
produce that random video but that is
basically it so whenever you do upload
another video to YouTube just go check
out and they are my uploading videos in
HD tutorial if you like and that will
give you a better idea of how actually
to upload the video and make sure you're
uploading the HD video and not the
original recording file and that's
basically it so I hope you I helped you
guys and um thanks for watching this
tutorial if you have any other tutorial
ideas for me or requests like this one
then go ahead and subscribe to my page
and send me a message and I will get
back to it as soon as I can thanks for
watching guys peace